can you give us an example of how you
helped one of your writers sell their
scripts and get a movie made so yeah i
have a
project that
i sold
and we basically worked on developing
the pitch together
and
we brought together to write producers
and team and made attachments
and we had a pitch
on zoom which made it very challenging
because this was during the pandemic so
this was a project to just make which
made it crazy is we sold a movie during
a
like dystopian you know
event like where we can't leave our our
place
so we prepped it on zoom
and
it was extremely like
challenging because you know a lot of
the process of selling an idea
is very physical you're in a room
together
and
it's it's cr it's something that you
have to have a presence but when you're
on a laptop like max headroom and you're
just like a floating head
it makes it infinitely more difficult
to sell a project
so
you know we had a tough situation you
know how do we make something really
good because we had you know a studio
executives that were going to be on a
zoom call so we decided that you know
the pitch that we just make
20 minutes make it just the best 20
minutes possible
because you know at a certain point the
tension span of most people
starts diminishing especially on a
screen
if you're in the physical world
it's so much easier to just like be
compelling and have
that kind of like
energy that everyone feeds from but when
you're looking at like you know your
laptop it's like completely different
so we decided that you know making it
shorter was better and the goal was
in the questions and answers we'd be
able to activate more interest and get
more information so we shortened this
pitch
way
smaller than
we'd ever do in a normal event would
make it much longer if we were in that
room so we shorten it
really practice it we ran the pitch
through multiple people
we actually had
and i think some people don't get it is
that like pitching is like writing you
have to iterate like i think some people
think you just show up and pitch but
actually pitching is kind of uh
when you think of like a performer like
a comedian they might even record
their sets just to hear do they hit all
the beats is it does it really resonate
or a musician could perform at a show
and then see people and really
get a sense of does that set work
so we had the writer go through all
these cycles of
prepping of different types of people
because we didn't know the energy
that was going to be given in that and
ultimately through
defining the the size of the pitch
prepping through multiple people
during this horrible event that we were
living everybody was living in and we
were able to
sell a movie
um
despite those challenges and it
resonated perfectly with the buyers
so i mean that is an event that like
collectively
we weren't looking at the pitch and
stuff something that's ready made and i
think that's a problem with a lot of
filmmakers there's like god just get
ready for the pitch but a pitch you
should even to me look at it like a like
a script
you get the script you kind of come up
the idea and you just refine it and you
iterate and you just keep making it
better and better a pitch should be the
same way you should be able to try it on
different people workshop it see where
people are at and don't just pitch
people that are already working on it
like you're just oh i just talked to my
collaborator you should get individuals
who are new to what you're talking about
and they should have notes for you what
ideas resonated do you rush by
exposition how did it develop and really
just making sure that the timing is
right
and
you know
is it exciting
do you get all the information across
and we really had this criteria
and ultimately it was successful because
we were taking that seriously
i have
a tv pitch going out soon we're doing
the same thing um because right now
we're we're still you know getting past
you know
this horrible situation to ultimately be
in the real world but i think that was
the valuable you know
you know experience was taking that
part of the equation as seriously as
writing that amazing script because if
it's just the pitch it's about trust why
should we trust you to be the one that
gets hired to
you know
write something
and you need to put that work in because
the person that you're pitching to if
they're valuable
if they're like high you know high
powerful
you know executive on the top of of a
major company
they don't have a lot of time
so you can't just kind of waltz in and
throw ideas around you have to like
really just
test your presentation to the point
where it's fantastic
it doesn't matter how long you've done
it too like it's not just doing it once
maybe you do it 10 times maybe you do it
more but it has to be at a point where a
new person who's never heard of this
project
sees it and if it's done on zoom that's
where the situation is it's fine
you move them you get them to go this is
something that i want to get behind and
that's uh what
was successful you know i sold multiple
projects so i think
that you have to when you sell these new
you know films or tv shows you want to
make sure that
the energy that of your idea is
transferring and the information is
to people who don't have the same level
of relationship that you do
and
it could have been harder
during the
during that time to
get make this work because it was so
unnatural to everybody involved but once
we were okay with it we're like this is
our
our frame
a screen this is the attention span we
designed it to
the user to the
individual who has the power to say yes
and that's why i was successful and
that's
my my role in this project was making
sure that
the pitch was ready for showtime
do you have the writer film themselves
and then you critique it or they even
watch themselves back to see how are
they coming across in the pitch
i don't have them look at themselves on
video but what i do is i firm it up with
them and then i just recommend them just
testing it on you know people they
respect
so get to the right length
and you're just hitting those beats over
and over again
it's almost like you want to make it
feel like it's natural
but it's not it's designed you know when
you do a certain expression or you know
when you pause they're going to lean in
it's so designed
that you're kind of taking them on a on
a journey but you know where the tracks
are
do you think most writers take too long
to get to the point because by nature
they love writing they love
communicating
and they need to shorten their message
i think there's no one
you know experience i've had on the on
the pitching front
but i do think that
it's very important and
that the people that
you want to
bring on as stakeholders in your
your in your movie or your tv show
they have a little window and you have
to get them
to care
because they might not they may not
start caring you have to take them from
potentially apathy
to really being invested and that's the
journey you have to take them take them
on in
it's really there's no one approach and
there's no one writer with a certain
temperament it's all across the board
but the more you
cycle through feedback and really
perfect it you have a better chance
of resonating with the right people
so a great writer and a great pitch
turns apathetic
people into sitting up straight in their
chair i mean they may not give you any
tells because an individual might just
be like this the whole time
so you might not know it's not to be
totally clear it's not
they're gonna applause or anything like
a big applause at the at the end of it
they might give you a poker face
okay
because maybe they don't want to give
you anything during this
time frame
because when you sell something
they're
spending money you know and maybe it's
maybe it's an investor maybe it's
someone who
you know has
a fund or maybe they know someone of
money whoever it is someone's taking a
risk
so you might not get
like any tells
that it's resonating you might just get
a very apathetic
expression
but
if they have all the information they
need to make a decision
once it's over
behind closed doors they might say it
was pretty cool but they might not give
that to you during that time because
they might lose power they have
more of ability to really think it
through if there's a wall
that's up over here
because then they could
think about it they could talk to
collaborators and really discuss the
opportunity it doesn't matter if they
have a reaction or not you know you've
tested it on all the right
you know individuals that give you
feedback so
regardless of
the emotional reaction of who's
listening at the end of the day is you
know you're ready
that's what matters
almost envision yourself
at like a
live poker you're watching live poker on
tv and you see these people with the
dark shades and the and the cat pulled
down and almost envision yourself
pitching in front of them and you know
there's going to be no reaction no
they're not even going to scratch their
nose to give away some kind of
discomfort or nervousness absolutely but
there could be another
type of
you know potential buyer who talks all
the time
so you just want to be able to
test your pitch out on
all sorts of personalities if you don't
know who you're pitching
is it just going to be like a quiet you
know
room
that has low energy
that could be the case or somebody keeps
cutting you off
you have to be ready and flexible
to get your message out
in a confident professional way
so there could be high energy hyper
almost like a caged animal
type of a
pitch not on the writer's part but of
the of the person being pitched you just
don't know who they are right i mean
it's just like anybody you know we all
have different personalities
if you don't know who you're pitching
you could be ready for any type of
energy
you
pull them in
and they really feel something
you might know you might not know it
doesn't matter you just need to know
you're ready for it
with this call the zoom pitch that
you're talking about how many people
were on the call and then was the
project purchased after the zoom call
like immediately after
i think it was might have been
five or six i don't really completely
remember you know everybody that was on
it but it was about it was about five or
six and
it wasn't bought on the call um there
was like you know we heard later you
know typically i haven't experienced
anything that just happens in the moment
where somebody would commit to
so that it typically has a bit of a
delay
where people have to regroup
like do you know how much like
did you hear maybe a month later
a week later
i think it was a
i think it was about a week or so okay
so you didn't lose too much sleep but no
you were you were waiting and then once
do you get do you get an email that says
it's a go we're having people draw up
contracts or do they have more questions
there were there really weren't any more
questions
on this event it wasn't
didn't continue
to like pull
information from the players involved in
this project
it was
established on that uh one pitch
oh okay so then the email was basically
we love it it's a it's a green light
yeah the phone call was like that yeah
oh okay nice
how long was the final curated pitch are
you talking about the the pitch
that does that include the q a
afterwards
oh so so there's the pitch and then the
five people and there's a q a um well
some people on the who are being pitched
to have some questions but it wasn't a
lot
i would say in in total i think that
this
this one for about
30 minutes
like because what happens also too
it starts with a little bit of like you
know small talk
so first is a small talk then there's a
pitch and then there's like a little
questions and answers
but that was it was about half an hour
and you know this is a silly question
but in a time of sensitivity
what is acceptable small talk because
you could really say the wrong thing and
you think you're joking
and you're just being sarcastic whatever
what is an acceptable
realm of small talk and and how should a
writer behave
just like any other job that the writer
might have had what is an expectation if
you
worked
in an office or if you're a student in
college it's what you know
you would uh do in these settings that
you just have to hold a you know
a serious uh presentation of yourself
it's not a
a space to be
acting you know
so out of like
you know out of that frame because
there's an expectation
that
when you're
in this kind of room is that they're
taking a risk on you
when you're trying to get
somebody
to invest in you
and there's money on the line
why do you go in their shoes how do they
if you're them what kind of person would
you want to risk a fortune on
you know and that should
you know establish
how you behave is you just have to have
empathy for them
and if you do
then you know how you initially present
yourself will be
the right professional face
well there's different cultures in
different workplaces i've worked in
somewhere
you know nothing but the facts don't
don't refer to anything that's not work
related whereas there's others where
people
shared personal details of their life
and that was the norm
it was probably too far on the spectrum
but just knowing like reading the room
like going in because some people might
have a little bit of more of a looser
style but you don't want to overstep
that bound
and that's an easy line to cross
especially these days you know well i
mean
this is most likely
a new relationship
uh in when i'm talking about if you
don't know
what their approach
to their business is is that you might
not know them that well or know them at
all
if they're a stranger then more of a
neutral
approach makes sense
because you can have the empathy that
if this investor is going to finance
your film
you could come out with more of a
baseline because you don't know them
and you don't have to perfectly match
their energy but you have to be
respectful of what kind of
dynamic they're going to get into if
they're good at green light your movie
so i think the key is not leading with
assumptions
and just
imagining what it would be like to be
sitting down in the other chair and
having to take a major risk on someone
you don't know or barely know
in the terms of this online pitch during
the pandemic that we're referring to was
this an existing relationship or did you
start this during did you reach out to
this person during the pandemic
i i'd say that
some parties had a relationship with the
buyers some didn't it was a mix
you